clac cette anxiété inexpliquée que tu
que tu partages avec van gogh et dont
lui se libère par une balle est ce que
toi tu es citant libérer ce que tu es si
la psychanalyse par exemple vous
aimeriez anxiété anxiété il ya l'entité
qui peut être provoquée par le trac ce
qu'on appelle un piti ce calme dès que
tout arrive assez faible puis l anxiété
qu'on n'arrive pas bien définir alors là
soit on se cherche soi-même voilà on
veut on fait appel à des psy ou des
choses comme ça mais pas tout à fait mon
truc mais j'en ai vu un oui oui mais sa
maman tu m'as vu aussi des salles et
combien de fois chez le psy j'ai pas
alors non ça ne se compte pas tout on
arrive même à oublier le nombre de fois
où on y va enfin lui maintenant il un
entonnoir
je pense qu'il va mieux et s'est ainsi
la religion va essayer on n'essaye pas
une religion par rapport à ma famille
oui donc j'ai une espèce de quand tu
étais petit mais depuis ça t'a par la
religion sert à croire d'abord à quelque
chose et peut-être à servir de se croire
à croire en soi déjà ici on arrive un
petit peu à croire en soi on peut
peut-être croire à une certaine religion